welcome Nick Foley hi buddy Jim how are
you thank you Sam hey I didn't recognize
you without the hair it looks it looks
much more comfortable it's way more
comfortable it was what were you were
inside a little bit about the memoir
today and I'm not forcing you guys into
mentioning it right away I'm just saying
stemming from my portrayal last year I
had a bleached the back in front of my
hair right so if I have this wig and if
a child were to see it would be white or
that's commitment
all right commitment yeah but I was also
the wp general manager and that looks
awful there were some weird moments at
WME TV when you're going through your
Santa fails because I had I had to take
a white beard and diet yes and I see
people who think he's good killing with
a jet black beard affected I'm working
on something here but anyway I went
never a good idea when a grown man takes
a pair of scissors and starts cutting
their own hair and the more I cut away
the back the more damage I did and then
I just showed up in New Orleans and said
just just take it all on your full
mansion right now with the beard and the
hair that's right man prison Manson
now do you but you got to keep the beard
for Santa because it's important that
you have a real what do you still like
Christmas or do you hate shower on it I
yeah I shave every like the December
28th and then just start over man now do
you shave it clean not as my wife thinks
I was soft dull we looking chin just
enough enough and then I start off start
all over I like that you're not like
that's you're that you're that you're
grooming style is take it all off and
then let it all come back like but once
you get it off right like then as soon
as I showed up my son is 14 who does a
killer Sam Roberts invitation by the way
really everyone hates him just ran the
gun know al I know your father
ice 14 lat I have had disorder the
second time I've been short air in 30
years I walk in the door and he like
recoils and he goes you look like my dad
and he wanted me to you know to grow it
out I was like if you do it once it's a
mistake you know yeah keep for a year
then it's a little look how do you like
it now though I do like you you know I
do like it honestly I look back at when
I was raw GM and I had the long hair and
a long beard and I can't believe I you
know was an authority figure sure with
that look are you still the GM no I get
fired and not spectacular
why why do you fired well I honestly I
needed to have my hip replaced and my
knee replaced and so there was gonna be
a lot of downtime and they could have
you know I could have wait sure but but
Kurt Angle is available and man that's a
tough job it's like just you you know
you travel quite a bit for me just with
the horrible pains which thankfully are
going going away it was just tough to
get on those planes and and but the
money lost is a big hint right they tell
us that you have a gig no you don't mind
I actually do better on my own doing
that job the money okay correct okay and
I wanted to be like you true to that job
so I didn't do outside while I was doing
it but um but as soon as it was as soon
as the gig was up and I was it was a
great gig and and as soon as you start
that job for anyone who knows w to be
like the authority figure like it
doesn't have a lot of long-term and you
know job security and really the best
you can hope especially I've got
Stephanie McMahon who's a great you know
great on-air character like I just want
to be fired in spectacular fashion just
to get somewhere yeah fired in
spectacular fashion help someone's you
know on the show there's story along the
way and hopefully you know help help out
a few guys along the way and it was
couldn't have asked for a better firing
we got it involved in a storyline and
it's definitely wrote but I'll go out I
was a beautiful forward for my book oh
nice beautiful all right there VIN said
no and then she was available
[Laughter]
I'm not knocking anybody but you know
most forwards right yeah you know when
Stephanie I was worried my publisher
said just see how she's doing and we
haven't heard anything and I said Steph
not to rush you but any word on the
progress she said I I should be done
with my first draft this week I'll be
sending it out for for proofreading I
was like first draft and I said I wrote
Dede peas in 90 minutes while I watch TV
but then it kind of shows that you are
you wrote it in 90 minutes so yeah when
that thing came out it's good you know
how long is the forward I rigged I wrote
a couple recently so I'm asking how it's
probably three pages yeah that's right
three pages really but it's really good
arguably better than anything that's in
the book itself so you might want to buy
although I mean it's good I feel like
there is pressure to write your forward
because maybe at first it was I got one
what do you mean mankind wrote a book
but now you're an author like people
know you can write and so it's like if
you're gonna write the foreword for
Foley's book it actually has to be
something I believe she did worthwile
Russian you know believe she felt a
little pressure you did was it how is it
working with her on screen is it is it
different now is the pressure different
now than it was it was you know really
it was really helpful for me because as
celebrated and exciting as my career was
I did some things may not have been wise
you know and so it's rude health-wise
you mean health wise and concussion wise
and so the short-term memory isn't what
it once was so I can I got a through
constant repetition I can commit things
to memory when it comes to doing like
the show on stage you know it's a
combination of you know recalling things
working on things ad-libbing and then
I'll have the Pete Davidson showed me
the the magic marker on the back of the
water bottle I never thought about notes
on a stool but you do have some notes no
I don't have any I do when I go out
there I have the I do that's what Pete
showed me he puts in the bag of all
bottle and so good you go to take the
drink and so I don't get lost but out
there and W if nothing so right before
we went out I said to Stephanie and
Stephanie and said I'm going to get lost
out there I'm not gonna panic because I
know it's gonna happen but if you would
be there with like a couple of words get
me back on track to be really helpful
and this was like every time or once
this is the first time sure and so I
knew I was gonna blank out and get lost
I didn't know I get lost in the first
ten seconds the Spanish one of the
Spanish announcer says did Stephanie say
four alarm fire to you yes she did and
it got me back on track so she was
really helpful to work with really
really a professional like you never
steered with a false move and just a
good person well how many concussions if
you had you know what I used to count on
it as eight but those were like alright
I'm throwing up you know the major then
as we learn more we like Boston Center
for traumatic encephalopathy I think it
changed the name now but as long as I
can continue to say those words I know
I'm okay see right i CT yeah then they
start saying well how many times we've
seen stars and I was like oh now we're
getting into the hundreds you know wow I
was like the sign that something looked
good if you saw stars you know and that
they didn't know it wasn't it's like
getting hit in the head but like a lot
of stuff it was like really just high
impact body blows you know like off the
ring apron that also shakes your head
it's your head on yeah so I could I
couldn't even guess you know but with WW
having that impact test that that really
saved me because when I took that it was
clear that there was a problem with the
short-term memory get to two
neurologists independent of each other
just both say and now you're done so
have you had are you scared now of
what's gonna happen if you had like a
scan done I don't want to say scared
concerned okay you know you guys were
nice enough that me on when I would
start you know starting
you know with the comedy or one man they
K they kind of graduated in one man
shows when I went to Just for Laughs and
I was I was trying to I was trying to
like run from my wrestling past you know
and then I go to go to Just for Laughs
so I look around like there's 250
funnier people in this building you know
and that like I'm kind of chasing people
away from the thing that makes me you
know I gives me a voice so so I kind of
accepted it and and and and once I got
started working within those confines I
found it was a lot more fun yeah kind of
found my voice but it was really it's
really serious for me for a couple of
years as a way of exercising my mind and
I I hope I'm okay like I was out there
and I was working on the Indy writing a
book you know as like he said it's
almost as if instead of your body having
trouble having to work on that you know
if your minds been through some
difficulty you got to find ways to
exercise it and you could also being the
wrestler is not it's not like it's it's
a thing that makes you like you said it
gives you the voice but you can still
talk about anything you could still like
that's just your base you're not limited
to what you can talk about yeah I can
see like a tether so anyway it's Heather
yeah here's your wrestling I can go off
it I can talk about anything as long as
I bring it back to how it happened
through somebody I met even rested it
seems to work that way
and you can get opinions you still Mick
Foley a guy they like they're coming did
not come and I see you to take bumps in
the ring or they like you so that they
want to hear what you have to say what
your opinions are and they just enjoy
you so I think you'd be surprised how
far you can go with that without you
don't hit the tie everything in a
wrestling I think the people just like
you in general think you're giving
giving everyone involved far too much
credit is it difficult to be an on
screen like authority character and know
that you cannot take bumps you cannot
have a match it is because I think that
was one of the limiting one of the
factors that limited me is that bad
on-screen guys got to be able to stand
up like once a year right you know and
say hey who do you you know like I'm
Kirk freaking angle you know like yeah
that's a you'd have to believe Kurtz got
another one
if I could have done one match a year
yeah that'd be a you know there was a
Triple H and I had great chemistry you
know and playoff Stephanie and it would
have been easy to work in a match if I
was capable of doing it but uh you know
it's for the for the best
well yeah it's it's that's one of the
limitations if you can't physically get
involved once in a while you can't do
quite the job and it seems like that's
happening more to his you know Daniel
Bryan's got the same thing like the more
people know about concussions the more
likely it is that somebody's like you
know what I know you don't feel like
you're done but you're done and then it
becomes this thing like we can use you
over here but yeah so yeah Dan you know
Daniel got cut at least when I you know
when I when I was evaluated and told I
was done I was only working one match he
you know a year or so Dana was in the
prime of his career you know and just
Jim just had made like that first year
of good money and it was devastating to
him yeah me it was kinda was kind of a
relief you know to actually have he's
like the different like having your
manager throw in the towel for you what
is he doing now he's the general manager
of SmackDown and he also just had as a
child
okay wife brie I think life's pretty
good for the dude
so it sucks when it happens especially
when you're younger but in 20 years
you're probably like wow I'm glad it
happened then so he's just got to get
through this period and go like okay
when you look back and you realize I
took a lot less hits in the head than I
had to
and that's trickiest and this is a my I
write about in my book it's called is
this st. make it's called a safe book
calm are you doing signings by the way
yeah I begin tonight in Ridgewood New
Jersey and book ends tomorrow great
place yeah it's when uh yeah it's one of
the best independent Barrington know
blue Tribeca tomorrow
Huntington Thursday book review another
great store and then the next week we go
to Connecticut a suburb of Cincinnati
Joseph Beth booksellers Santa Claus
Indiana at the Santa Claus Museum oh boy
that's gonna be a big one yes I see you
already have your Santa shirt oh man
I'm ready to go but in the in the book I
talk about that like that the hardest
thing for almost every wrestler is
trying to find something that makes them
feel like they did when they were out
there Wow and so for me getting on the
stage is and they're you know and
they're granted there are nights when
things do not go well sure but then you
you really learn from those nights and
then you end up getting material from
those nights yes sorry do you advise me
to tape it with a GoPro every set every
set I can't stand listening myself you
don't have to sometimes you do with a
video camera you have someone put like a
little GoPro video and if there's a
moment that you say that you're not sure
of you can go back and watch it and you
have to watch a minute of yourself but
you don't want you don't want you of
course not and resume no no sometimes
you just knowing that you're taping your
mind goes I can do anything right now
because I have it I won't lose it
especially if you're concerned that your
memory might not be what it was if you
videotape every moment look at it like
you maybe you'll do a documentary on it
someday maybe you won't but if you do
something that's amazing like [ __ ] what
was that oh I have it even if something
gets a laugh like how did I word that
yes and if you never watch it it still
frees you up mentally because you know
you're taping and when you're freed up
mentally you know you can go anywhere
and you'll grab it I will do that yeah
it's helped me a lot go the GoPro have a
GoPro hooked up there are a few hundred
bucks and it's a write-off
yeah you just lost me is worth doing I
am pretty tough for myself you know and
I finally and I want to make every show
a little better and there's a ton of you
I know you know that and you probably
sometimes hang on to something and
discard it because you can't find it
yeah and this is you can say any words
you want here right yeah yeah and one of
the things I do I only curse once in a
you know in a set started to see I was
trying to talk about how when Kevin
Sullivan asked me about my finish when I
was going to be wrestling the Steiners
in 1989 it caught me out of the blues I
saw my name against the Steiner
contemplated quitting the business as
others have either they can be really
rough and then Kevin sold his brother
what's your finish and I just call me I
just said I
of a dropping elbow and so the what I
was saying was that when elbow without
further explanation can seem weak benign
and ice borderline pussy-ass
yeah and I it wasn't getting reaction
you know like I was like I know that
there's gotta be a way to make this work
and then one night I went out there and
I said at elbow drop for finish without
further explanation may seem weak benign
borderline Hogan esque and then it went
then they would that you know and here
comes the reaction and I went he's not
here tonight is he yeah and then I went
sorry brother and I got the three there
I got the three laughing ah man I got
and it was really rewarding that way so
everything you know I like that process
of going out on the roads I'm gonna be
going out April May and June first time
in a couple years and let that be a note
to young comics too that if you're if
you're struggling with something replace
the word [ __ ] with bogan absolutely am
I going to get a laugh sure you know
yeah are you gonna get kicked right in
the Hogan yeah exactly nothing worse
than that what was the last time you
bombed
yeah and stage well I hadn't done in a
while but I just finished okay drew
Alliance and April 2016 I'm done and
then we did the reality show and they
want me to do a I'm here to do a set for
the reality show how come you didn't
wanna do anymore ah you know what
happened to me and maybe you can advise
me on this I went out there with a bunch
of things I wanted to do this is after
watching TIG Notaro sat where she talked
about her breast cancer sure and I'm
like man I I'm not talking about this
journey I had through you know these
head injuries and and I had a bunch of
stuff and it was like after like ten ten
days and like this is not what people
want to hear well you're also looking at
take though she was a seasoned comic
like you I mean she had been on the road
for probably ten years before that or
eleven years so if you're going and
you're tackling something that's a
little bit harder or a little like where
the humor isn't naturally gonna pop out
that might be a muscle you need to work
a little bit but you shouldn't give up
you should just keep trying it and if
they
here it well then you tell it in a way
where they do want to hear but you just
got to give it some time I I could sense
that people who do want to hear about
the head I couldn't maybe there was a
way but you know Sam and I were just
talking about the fact that these shows
coming out in the next spring we're
gonna be 20th anniversary of Hell himsel
says he's based on that one show so
you're right this show around one match
twenty years ago and so I said it's
almost like when Springsteen does the
river you can't walk out and be upset
that he did the river because it's not
even the thing is the river but when I
was reading his biography they said like
there was some some albums like the
rising that caught on with everyone and
the new songs we went over big and then
he had to admit at a certain point like
there was one album that just wasn't
connecting and then you just say okay
we're not gonna force them on people
we're not gonna play them and that's
kind of how I felt and so I went back I
was like all right let me find kind of
finding old pieces of material bringing
them in and and it wasn't as fulfilling
for me and so I just felt I had been
running hard for six straight years and
and and going through a lot of material
and I said I'm just gonna take a break
and I'm gonna come back when I really
want to do it which I do but going back
to bombing I went in and did a show just
for our reality show and it was one of
those nights where they they have a
fundraiser going on oh [ __ ] a bunch
of people we don't belong on a show
they're donating money they're [ __ ] I'd
rather hand over money and then just
trash whatever the project is just keep
their talk in there's like 50 people
there they're raising money for the cars
I said location what is your cause and
they give you things cause I will write
you a nice check if you just leave you
know like the only laugh I got you know
and it was frustrating but everything
else was just nothing well you know it
was just throwing stuff out there just
for the sake of getting some lines on
the on the show yeah I could say I kind
of bombed there but it's a healthy you
may be surprised if you went up at the
LA improv or other places like that just
as Mick Foley and a lot of people would
know you some may not
and you start from that and you hey I
was a wrestler and you almost talked to
people who don't know you is intimately
you might be surprised how much more
they want to hear about head injuries
because they're not looking at you like
you're [ __ ] mankind they're just
looking at you like hey here's this
interesting guy he's obviously built
like a wrestler and he has something to
tell us that we don't know you you might
be surprised how well you do with crowds
that aren't there to see you it's a good
point and you should try it because you
want to talk about it I was talking with
a guest you had on recently Illya
Jeanine oh yeah sure she's sweet and I
was like maybe I would would you mind if
I tried a couple of your shows you know
like I used to but you know she has an
all-female like one token guy so to go
out and like being an environment that's
not there for me like I guess turday I
was asked I did a live signing and I
said being of the live sighting deal
where they film you in your sign yes for
questions and I said question what's
your pet peeve and I knew I what I want
to say but I think I know
ice I'm gonna say I don't I know this is
gonna sound oh no my pet peeve is the
guys who go out there and do q and A's
the wrestlers I said because there's no
commitment there's no work there's no
sense of failure like they're like I I'm
so thankful for those days I had where I
just bombed like I'm thankful but for
the one day in particular Judah
Friedlander was there too because if you
hadn't been there when I tanked at the
Gotham one night I never would have gone
on a stage really good ball munching huh
in wrestling things are going poorly you
can always pull out a big move if you're
losing a crowd and and you and you don't
know how to get them back it can be the
most I'm a guy who's known to take a a
lot of pain trust me the mental anguish
from sucking hmm his neck you know
nothing I did in the ring
compared to that night in Gotham where I
just hope that a hole would open up in
the stage so I could jump that was the
worst because it's exposing it's like oh
my god
they they see me for what I am which is
this [ __ ] uninteresting lump it's
like being under a spotlight and they're
asking you a question you don't have the
answer for it but yeah it happens to all
of us and it no matter how long you're
I'm doing it a lot longer and I'll have
a night like that girl well I will be in
the [ __ ] the cellar or the village
underground and and like 27 years and
let you have to go into everything
you've learned and maybe you pull out a
few laughs and even then it's a mild
titter this nice but you just can't do
it and that's a part of it
but that is like the the poster for why
fear of public speaking is such a big
deal you're talking to a guy who
literally had his ear ripped off in a
foreign country and had doctors shouting
at him in Germany and in German and he's
going like the other been in that right
see room in Munich then on that stage
the only thing I got applause for wasn't
I just looked at the audience I said I
was in a pool I would ask for a life
preserver because I'm drowning up here
he said that and I walked off the stage
and Judah was there and he goes dude
it's not as bad as you thought you know
I'm never going on stage again he goes
dude go dude
cuz don't get me wrong he goes he goes
you have an advantage over other people
because they were listening use anyone
else goes four minutes without a laugh
they're done all four minutes huh oh
yeah you taping that that's what you
should take like you understand in the
documentary if you're doing something
how interesting that is to watch someone
bomb you and wine it would you watch
therefore all four minutes on a loop I'd
literally watch it I'd plan my Friday
people listen you and he looked me in
the eye goes dude don't get me wrong you
got to find a way to make this stuff
funny yeah and then he proceeded to take
me to school and from that point he
bring me down you know four or five
clubs and a night you know and that's it
I'm more of a storyteller than a joke
guy to get five minutes it's difficult
for me but I would get in there and I
would you know work on it and you start
you know you get used to it and you
build up that tolerance for like that
punishment you know and I so I want it I
want to get out there again before I hit
the stage even though it's going to be
you know a show based on one
it's 20 years ago I kind of know where I
want to go with it I still think it's
really healthy to get out there and fail
on a spectacular level it is because
it's one of those things where you do
learn from that and you know it's a part
of it it's just a part of it it's it's
not it's not no it's it's uncomfortable
and it happens and it sucks but when you
look at it what is it really like you
really literally are just standing there
and people are not giving you the
emotional reaction you want like we take
it as this horrible rejection this but
it's all it is is a bunch of people just
going no yes that's the barrier no one
no one's hurting you no one's throwing
the [ __ ] glasses at you you're saying
huh and they're going no that's all it
is but you're right it is so exposing
that's how you feel nude and you feel
like they're right you feel like every
audience has ever left is a fool and my
god these people collectively have it
right [ __ ] and they know it's right it's
nothing all you're insecure sure and
they're all like right in front of you
yeah you watch I'm dying up here on
Showtime I did not know how man I
thought they really nailed it you know I
know it's 70s is that Jim Carrey's thing
yeah no I didn't say there's there's a
moment where the young female lead
greener I believe is her last name and
she wants to go and do something other
than just I'm the country girl from
Wenck Texas and Goldie who's amazing
melissa leo she's amazing the other Club
she's highly advising her against it and
the way they shoot it you know she's
going on her thing and you're looking
out a shooting her from like over the
shoulder and you see that crowd just
nothing crickets and you're rooting for
her you know you know she's trying
something a little out there and then
when she starts to get him it's like
it's almost like the 14th round of Rocky
you know like and I was like that's
exactly what it's like you know so I
wanna yeah I highly advise it you know
I'd like to see it did she get them in
the first set
like is she bombing when she tries this
and all of a sudden halfway through the
said she gets them yes okay that's
fiction
no she would've eaten her [ __ ] chest
for a month did you like doing the
reality show we did
we did like it a lot
yeah the opportunity came up and I you
know anytime you can work with your
family right that at home for 10 weeks
you know and do something that I thought
turned out to be pretty good
III we really we really enjoyed it you
know yeah it was great we kind of wish
in a way we should be done in a second
season but on the other I was like you
know we did one season the family came
out intact right you know like we did
okay
why didn't you do the second one was it
do network didn't want to what you guys
said oh you know I just I think the WWE
was so high on it that they thought it
might bring in non wrestling fans to the
network and I never thought that was a
pop I never those realistic and it
didn't happen it did good ratings for
them on the network and it was an
expensive show to make you know like it
was it was it was really well done with
a you know top production team and
shooting you know on location even
though the location was our our house or
the house that we moved into for change
to look like our well you have two
cameras and stuff they need something a
wired a certain way there's no way that
they would have been shooting in one
room you know like and I think they just
realized that there were other things
they could do that would be almost as
popular that weren't nearly as expensive
now your daughter became very popular
off that did you guys only stick to
wrestling stuff though because if you
wanted to bring in people outside the
family may be outside the world you
might have had to go into other areas to
get people interested I think we did a
pretty good job okay there's a thread
you know her working on her trying to be
I would say trying to be a wrestler but
when you're on the show you have say a
WWE super super sized event say I don't
understand what you're saying right now
oh you know I think there's a drinking
game every time my daughter says WWE
supers you know mr. McMahon years ago
we're not wrestling we're WW / stars and
his branding can be you know sometimes
you know there are times when he will
choose for like announcers to not be
able to say certain words that don't
seem to make sense
afterward
like if you have a when a guy wins let
me see you win this thing and you put it
over your shoulder it is a championship
strap on I'm sorry I'm hold on
a hat oh okay a what
your no belt is forbidden it's taboo on
there so uh no you can't see can't I won
the belt can't belt and never a strap I
got strapped with no what do you say
that the WWE Championship belt
ampionship title championship title it's
not no and then uh you know braun
strowman is broncos six 80s three
hundred and sixty pounds monster among
men and yeah monster mo man he goes Aziz
and I'm about ready to intercede and he
goes I want my title shot okay here
missing back I'm thinking but I don't
know why sham pionship opportunites
exactly what I said and I made sure when
I went out there I said so you'd like a
championship opportunity there's just
certain things see obviously and I'll
tell you why I think that's a mistake
from the outside because by doing that
when you're saying things like belt and
title shot you cuz wrestling has had to
kind of come out and go yes we're
entertainment but by saying that stuff
it's kind of putting it back into the
realm of other combat sports like almost
if you're using certain combat sport
lingo people know that it's
entertainment but it's you don't want to
separate it so much that it makes it
obvious it's only entertainment use
combat sport lingo of course they do it
so this Bach everyone does I want to
shot at the belt that's I want to title
w/e is always and that's where the
wrestling and superstar and wrestler
that all that branding comes in because
even wanted to be separated from other
wrestling wrestling organizations like
there is wrestling and there's combat
sports and there's this and there's that
and then then there's WWE it's like
Disney I definitely but I think there's
some times you probably don't need to do
it because while the branding is
brilliant that he's done you might
overdo it and then certain natural
language you don't use and people
ecologist seem to shoehorn it doesn't
seem comfortable I'm in complete
agreement with you especially when it
comes to mr. McMahon's disdain for
profit
pronouns like wait is there so these are
like pronouns
oh no then this is coming from number
one New York Times bestselling author
like I believe once you establish the
subject you can then use a pronoun sure
you know like you know Mark Henry you
know Mark Henry out there he's got that
bear he's got that bear hunt we know
it's Mark Henry Mark Henry he's really
good Henry Henry with the you know use
constant repetition yeah and that's I
understand that but that's not the New
York Times does that mr. Foley then went
on to say mr. fold like the New York
Times will do something like that that's
right you can't avoid all pronouns
pronouns improperly used sausage buckle
now I would like you to take a turn at
wwk Minh Terry you were I think I feel
like you were the first guy that really
started talking about what was going on
behind the behind those magical headsets
I said they're magical headsets because
you put them on and everything you
accomplished over the course the last 15
years it's disappeared there was a girl
named a female wrestler there Laila I
remember yeah surely well and when I
returned to W to be after some time off
she was like cowering backing away she
was terrified of me why and she would
say that I was like the meanest person
she'd ever seen fair based on one
interaction she observed with me and mr.
McMahon where I did not take well to
being cursed at on the headset you know
oh and she just happened to be there
well I just I just snapped you know I
snapped and I don't care talk to me that
way ever again he's not at him stop -
mr. McMahon Wow
and so then it was like and then it was
like three years later or the same
finger that was like wagging in his face
was dialing the phone and going did that
end your relationship
yeah okay and how was it how was um same
finger huh how much those probably won
over actually one of the how was a mr.
McMahon when you called mr. McMahon
actually been a year and a half since we
spoken and I got a message on the phone
and he was like I know you don't like me
but I know you love this company there
was a there was a time when they I guess
people were bad-mouth from the company
he wanted me to weigh in on you know my
feelings and I called him back and I
went I love Vince and he goes I make us
I like you like I do deep down I really
I like him he didn't like being spoken
to that I didn't like that job it wasn't
the right job for me like I was I was a
pat in the back guy not a kick in the
butt you know and I didn't deal well
with that but that's uh and I don't know
like about I've talked to other
broadcasters and no one else goes
through that but he's just such a he
cares so much about every aspect of the
product you know that he's in my mind
like you're not calling what you see in
the ring you're calling what you see on
the monitor like you've got to get into
that role where everything you see there
becomes real you know and it's similar
like when I'm say going into my new book
saying man that's a great book yes but
what I'm when I have a visit like with
and I'm not talking so much about the
long lines but like a hospital visit or
something where you have some time with
a child like you get into that character
to the point where you like you feel
like you're the guy you know and that's
the biggest because they want the
character to get the cat well the kids
yeah I mean you know the kids most of
the time they go I mean you see it in
every movie like all right I know you
work for him like in home alone like how
it works you know so the highest form of
flattery this is when I started
volunteering for group called Christmas
magic they called me in I to do their
the the guy had found in this charity
after 30 years he had rotator cuff
surgery couldn't do any lifting so he
asked me about to take over his role and
I felt like I was being called in from
the bullpen you know for the seventh
game of the World Series and so I went
here and these are the kids and
homeless shelters and foster assurance
and so I went there and I go all out you
know it's the beard and whatever
mannerism you like Christmas there was
snow cones on your shirt there were
little sent a hit when I came back a
couple days later was for another event
the social workers going do you know
what the children were saying on the bus
and I said no what they were they were
going that was the real Santa and it was
like the greatest compliment you know
like sure that's the biggest compliment
so like going back but that's like you
know you're here with that your child
you're telling these stories that you
know that you've come up with you're
trying to make this best experience if
somebody's in your headphones
yelling at you yeah taking you out of
that world it would be really difficult
for the real Saint Nicholas because they
do put think they found it but it's
under a marble floor but the actual
Saint Nick they believe they have
located where his body is buried I would
open with that I go to but they do think
they found it he's apparently very good
guy well you like being yelled at so
when you guys talk the visit man seems
at the type of guy that he can be like a
real heart but here's the irony I did
enjoy being yelled at by Stephanie on
air you did you like that well it's part
of the gig though you thought it was
part of the thing yeah not so much
Stephanie in person very much Vince
seems to know that like he knows he's a
Yeller and hidup I knows he can be very
harsh so he seems like the type of guy
that can forgive and forget - I'm sure
he's had enough run-ins with people he's
had to go you know what forget it that
was the past yeah absolutely I was told
like I want him on this show Sam won't
take him on the show the big what I
didn't realize is none of it was
personal it feels personal and then I
went up to WB headquarters to do the
Edge and Christian show and Vince's top
producer Kevin Dunn asked me to stop by
and he goes Vince Vince would like to be
in touch with you more often and I I
went really like hey he does it bothers
him you
he's good relationships with people who
felt built this company he doesn't have
that with you and I so I said please you
want me to cite text to them you know
and I said hi Vince McFaul would you
mind if we stayed in touch a little more
regularly I would like that I said do
you want to talk on the phone in a
couple days and at that time I was down
from 338 pounds to like 313 and I told
him when we talked about I said you know
no one's ever told me this but my I'm
guessing the reason I'm not on comeback
I'm not on television because it's
difficult to watch me you know like I'm
having a lot of trouble getting around I
said just want no I'm working on it and
my goal is to lose 80 pounds by the
holidays you know 80 pounds one year and
the moment I heard him say I'm gonna
hold you to that it was the moment I
knew that I was going to do it you know
so when I showed up and did it two
months early you know came in at 2:58
and weighed in for him
he was like a proud father you know he's
been so proud of you Mick yeah that's
awesome yeah I genuinely I I think he
goes so far to say that I love mr.
McMahon Oh
anybody that's not is there anybody in
the company who isn't afraid of him I
mean he's he's the boss absolutely
how did you lose all the weight
oh man that's just not a show for that
is it just going to the gym and eating
better
yeah yeah the smaller meals more
frequently you lose a lot of the sugar
processed flour or a lot of vegetables
but the trick the hard thing years had
this knee replacement stuff right they
warned me when I had my Ripper place and
I was doing the physical therapy they're
like Nene's much tougher like why I like
it just it takes longer it hurts worse
how long something like this is only
been like five weeks
oh okay so it was probably ambitious to
start a book tour
well your honor your honor yes I got the
cane but it just it hurts at night and
you can't sleep when it hurts so trying
to get sleep has been really difficult
what do you take for it I try to
I tried the melatonin I and I try to
avoid pain pills right they're like you
can't you stay ahead of the pain don't
be the macho guy you can't get through
this operation without without some type
of pain medication so I try to take it
like a little bit before I go to sleep
but even then man it's just uh it's it's
a tough one and so as that relates to
the weight loss now at like 4:00 a.m.
when I feel those late-night binges and
I don't have mr. McMahon's voice going
I'm gonna hold you to that it seems to
make perfect sense to have four bowls of
children's cereal yeah yeah yeah I
understand that it's hard not to it's
hard not to you're healing up but you
know look it'll get better it will it
will get better as I'm sure it started
already yes the healing has begun yeah I
just admitted to loving mr. McMahon and
he did okay smart business move again
that wasn't the dumbest that you think I
haven't said I love Scott green see and
Andrew Moss I do my favorite people yeah
I started this book is gonna publish it
for a hundred self-published over 100
people now yeah because it was really a
very personal book and Stephanie was one
of two people convinced we might have a
larger audience I talked to her but she
sounds really interesting and then I saw
this tweet from Jason who's been
publisher editor and publicist like all
in one and he has his own I saw that he
had tweeted something that his favorite
interview had ever done was with me so I
went and I checked Jason Pinter out as I
come he got his own publishing company
and so this is my pitch right you know
how you're supposed to put everything
yeah sure out there the pitch and I was
like I know you guys don't do nonfiction
but if you know a small house that would
like to do a very small run and not have
much publicity I've got a project
because of first and foremost like I
want to get out of the I want to get out
of the process without hating my own
book and that hasn't always happened you
notice when you get behind it and you
did that sometimes dirty book signings
you know and it's like I never want to
look at it I understand it's on a shelf
and I worked really hard I don't ever
want to see it I don't ever want to
worry yeah because you dealt with it
you're done with it and this one it was
important to me like to important me too
over-talk it and I was worried that I
would come on and start talking
wrestling and make headlines for the
wrong reasons but I'm okay if the
headline from this is Mick Foley loves
Vince McMahon yeah loves Vince McMahon
get his new Christmas book Santa by by
the way the day after Christmas are you
like Christmas doubt like I'm right
already like you have to be impressed or
depressed
you must done sick of Christmas every
when do you get sick you but when do you
not want to think about Christmas ever
in a polity like Christmas it's like if
Willie Nelson sang a Christmas song and
said you were always on my mind and
substitute a woman for Christmas but
does the day of Christmas seem
anticlimactic because you talk about it
so much
no I actually had my best visit on
Christmas Day I had a really great visit
with a child who was so weary in the
hospital I didn't think he'd remember
the visit and I went about 5 p.m.
Christmas Day and felt like it was you
know among the finest performances that
ever you know it's just I was yeah it
was a really AB as a great moment for me
like it and then just look in the boy's
mother and aunt you know I was like I
was there for about 50 minutes and they
did you want a Santa yeah what is Santa
and it was yeah it was a really great
moment and then the next day I heard
about some some guys who had were
rampage through a house and Lindenhurst
and taking their Christmas decorations
like a ten foot tall minion and so I got
I like reached out i'm facebook found
the woman there was a news story and i
said could i come by was the new like a
new minion and so I did a visit to their
house in the 27th like Santa visit and
that was pretty magical too so ya know
what yes what are you go ahead uh-uh
yeah there isn't usually a downtime
after Christmas a lot of guys miss it
terribly and then I I just look forward
to doing it again and in front try to
find something else okay what have you
told your younger kids like when you
started doing the Santa thing do you
tell your younger kids like hey good
news guys I work for
exactly like whereisdan do you tell him
mr. Santo today I know it what the hell
what do you know they knew they were
still in that magic age and I would just
explain he can't be everywhere you know
especially in December it's not he can
feasibly make it around the world give
him time zone changes yeah sure yes a
lot of technical issues start out at the
aisle evolutions there is theoretically
a way you can make the journey but it
can't be everywhere at every mall every
day so he needs some help on the ground
he does and what I have you know see if
I could find my bag of Jason outside you
know let me make it up he's hurry that
last roof case okay so when I when I
like I know that it's it's not a book
for children it's like a g-rated butcher
so I'll have children at the event and I
think this clears everything up in a
hurry hard you guys could just talk
among ourselves that's fine we only have
a couple of minutes left
yeah so I'm gonna be um oh here it is
okay the letter I received from Santa oh
wow laminate laminate so the children
can look at it this is the dear Mick as
you know Christmas is the most wonderful
time of the year he sounds like Vince
world but a Santa grows older wishlists
grow longer expectations grow larger
I've come to understand that I can no
longer pleat all of my Santa duties on
my own so it is after great and careful
thought with great respect and
appreciation for the love with which you
hold Christmas in your heart for the
entirety of the year but I ask if you
would consider joining my team as an
ambassador for the very real spirit of
Santa Claus from this moment on would
you accept mine should you accept my
heartfelt offer you'll be known to me
the elves mrs. C is Santa make your
friends Santa oh I get eight or nine
year old which don't listen to your show
demographic I think I think you get an
extra extra year in the magic age I
think most an annual to read that and go
of all
of the centuries of Santa now he steps
down and I don't get him that's what I
would say oh my oh my god you're you're
you're the new Fred Flintstone I want
the old Fred Flintstone I don't like the
new one I mean it to me it looks like
Santa's hand right it looks like it to
me
by the way our pals at Barnes & Nobles
and Yonkers are tweeting us a photo of
Saint Mick yeah on shelves now